.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW WHATEVER THE OUTCOME IN THIS
GOP PRIMARY TONIGHT, IT'S TIME
TO PUT ASIDE DIFFERENCES, SHELF
THE PETTY SQUABBLES AND NIPPING
AT EACH OTHER AND COME BACK
TOGETHER TO TAKE BACK THE SENATE
IN NOVEMBER.
NOW, UNDER ONE PARTY CONTROL BUT
THE SCHUMER-PELOSI SOCIALISTS,
AMERICA IS GOING BROKE, WOKE AND
BECOMING A JOKE.
IT'S TIME FOR REAL OVERSIGHT OF
BIDEN'S RUN-AWAY FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND TIME TO SLAM THE
BRAKES ON HIS INFLATION-STOKING
AGENDA WITH A REPUBLICAN
CONTROLLED CONGRESS.
BUT THE LEFT, THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO GO DOWN WITHOUT A FIGHT.
NO WAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO HANG ON
TO THEIR POWER BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
WHEN THEY'RE NOT BLOWING UP THE
ECONOMY, THEY'RE SHIFTING BLAME,
BLOWING UP RACE RELATIONS OR
DISTRACTING WITH PHONY
NARRATIVES.
>> THE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT IN
DEMOCRACY IS IN A DANGER LIKE IT
HASN'T BEEN IN MY LIFETIME.
IT'S IN DANGER THIS HOUR.
HATE AND FEAR ARE BEING GIVEN
TOO MUCH OXYGEN BY THOSE THAT
PRETEND TO LOVE AMERICA.
>> IT'S FOR NO PURPOSE, NO
PURPOSE EXCEPT PROFIT AND/OR
POLITICAL BENEFIT.
IT'S WRONG.
>> Laura: HE'S HARKENING BACK TO
TRUMP.
MY LORD IS THIS PLAYBOOK
DOG-EARED OR WHAT?
MOST VOTERS KNOW THAT JANUARY 6,
BUFFALO, CHARLOTTESVILLE,
THEY'RE BIDEN'S GREATEST HITS.
THEY'RE NOT AMERICA'S GREATEST
HITS, THIS ISN'T GOING TO WORK
WHAT IS NEXT FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
I'M GOING TO CALL IT THE
POPULOUS PIVOT.
DEMOCRATS WILL TRY TO CLAIM THAT
THEY, NOT REPUBLICANS,
REPUBLICANING CHALLENGING ARE
THE TRUE POPULOUS.
THEY'RE THE ONES FIGHTING FOR
THE LITTLE GUY.
THEY'RE I'M RELATABLE PLOY IS
THE GO-TO DESPERATION MOVE.
>> I'M GLAD FOR EVERYBODY WHO IS
JOINING IN ON THIS VIDEO.
GREAT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
HOLD ON A SEC.
I'M GOING TO GET ME A BEER.
HEY.
MY HUSBAND, BRUCE, IS NOW IN
HERE.
YOU WANT A BEER?
>> I'LL PASS ON THE BEER FOR
NOW.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOSH, I FORGOT
ABOUT THAT.
THEN THERE'S SENATOR JOHN TESTER
WITH HIS FLAT TOP BUZZ CUT,
TOUGH GUY FORMER LOOK.
HE TRIED THE SAME THING IN 2018.
>> WASHINGTON FORGETS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING FOR US.
WITH SOME BUREAUCRAT BACK THERE
STANDS IN THE WAY IN MONTANA, I
LET THEM HAVE IT.
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
BETTER SCHOOLS, I'M WIRED TO
FIGHT ANYBODY.
I'M JOHN TESTER AND YOU'RE DAMN
RIGHT I APPROVE THIS MESSAGE.
>> Laura: YOU'RE DAMN RIGHT.
YOU VOTE WITH SCHUMER ALL THE
TIME.
HE'S JUST ANOTHER BIG SPENDING
LIBERAL.
>> WE HAVE TO DO THINGS IN A
POSITIVE WAY TO LOWER INFLATION.
WE DID WITH IT A BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL, WE DID IT
WITH THE RESCUE PLAN.
>> Laura: WHAT?
THE FACT IS THAT THE SO-CALLED
MODERATES LIKE TESTER AND
RAPHAEL WARNOCK, THE ONLY VOICE
CONCERNED ABOUT ISSUES LIKE
BORDER OR INFLATION WHEN IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT THE ISSUES ARE
HEARTING THEIR PARTY IN THE
MID-TERM.
WHERE WERE THEY IN 2020 OR LAST
YEAR?
IN THE BIG OPEN SENATE SEAT
CONTEST, TWO MORE LIBERALS ARE
ATTEMPTING THIS TRANSPARENT
BRANDING.
CONGRESSMAN TIM RYAN TRYING TO
BEAT OUT J.D. VANCE IN HALL OF
FAME.
NOW RYAN WHO VOTED WITH NANCY
PELOSI 100% OF THE TIME
ACCORDING TO PRO PUBLICA IS NOW
PRETENDING TO BE DONALD TRUMP ON
THE CHINA ISSUE.
>> DEFUNDING THE POLICE IS WAY
OFF THE MARK.
WE NEED MORE COPS, NOT LESS.
MY PARTY ALSO GOT IT WRONG ON
THE TRADE DEALS THAT SENT YOUR
JOBS OVERSEAS.
I'VE ALWAYS FOUGHT THOSE WORKING
AGAINST YOU.
>> Laura: YEAH, THIS COMPLETE
NONSENSE, BELIEVE NONE OF IT.
A VOTE FOR RYAN IS A VOTE FOR
CHUCK SCHUMER.
ON IMPORTANT ISSUES, CHEMOMENTS,
HE WILL NEVER CHALLENGE HIS
PARTY'S LEADERSHIP, NEVER.
AS FOR JOHN FEDDER MAN, WE WISH
HIM A SPEEDY RECOVERY, BUT
PENNSYLVANIANS SHOULDN'T BE
FOOLED BY THE SWEATSHIRT, JIM
SHORTS LOOK.
IT'S SLOPPY AND UNCONVINCING.
JUST LIKE THIS AD.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT TOWNS
IN PENNSYLVANIA THAT FEEL LIKE
THEIR COMMUNITY'S BEST DAYS WERE
A GENERATION AGO.
NOBODY DESERVES TO BE ABANDONED.
ALL OF THESE COMMUNITIES
DESERVED TO BE HELPED.
>> A DEMOCRAT WITH BACKBONE,
DOES THE RIGHT THING NO MATTER
WHAT.
>> NO MATTER WHAT?
THE RIGHT THING FOR FEDDERMAN
WILL ALWAYS BE KEEPING CHUCK
SCHUMER HAPPY, ALWAYS.
WITH THE OCCASIONAL EXCEPTION OF
JOE MANCHIN AND KRISTIN SINEMA,
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A
REALLY INDEPENDENT-THINKING
DEMOCRAT.
TAKE SENATOR MARK KELLY.
ARIZONIANS VOTED FOR HIM BECAUSE
HOW CAN A FORMER ASTRONAUT BE A
RUBBER STAMP FOR LIBERALISM?
DOESN'T COMMUTE.
IN FACT, THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S BEEN.
VOTING WITH SCHUMER 96% OF THE
TIME.
NOW, HE MUST REALLY THINK HIS
OWN VOTERS ARE STUPID THOUGH.
BECAUSE SUDDENLY AFTER A
MONK-LIKE SILENCE, KELLY SAYS HE
CARES.
>> WE'VE TAKEN ACTION FOR LOWER
COSTS AT THE GAS PUMP.
>> Laura: THERE'S NO OXYGEN IN
HIS POPULOUS ACT.
ZERO.
NOW, ANY VOTER THAT WANTS TO
TURN THIS ECONOMY AROUND, WANTS
TO END THE MADNESS AT THE BORDER
SIMPLY CANNOT FALL FOR THE
DEMOCRAT FAUX POPULOUS PITCH.
WHY WOULD GEORGE SOROS DONATE
MONEY TO SENATOR MARK KELLY OR
TIM RYAN IF THEY WERE GOING TO
TAKE ON THE ESTABLISHMENT?
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT SOROS
CASH POURING IN.
HE'S SEED AGO SUPER PACT WITH
$125 MILLION.
AN ENORMOUS INVESTMENT THAT WILL
AID DEMOCRAT GROUPS AND
CANDIDATES FOR THE 2020 ELECTION
CYCLE AND BEYOND.
SOROS KNOWS WHAT TIME IT IS IN
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AND IT AIN'T
THE POPULOUS TIME.
IT'S ALL GLOBALISTS ALL THE
TIME.
SO PAY NO ATTENTION TO THE
DEMOCRATS PREDICTABLE MASQUERADE
UNFOLDING MONTHS BEFORE THE
MID-TERM.
THEY'RE SENDING THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT WILL BE SPENDING YOUR
CHILDREN'S AND GRANDCHILDREN'S
FUTURE, SQUANDERING IT.
THE SAME PEOPLE BIDDING THE WORK
FOR THE TEACHER'S UNIONS AND
BLM.
SO WHEN YOU HEAD TO THE POLLS
THIS NOVEMBER, YOUR CHOICE IS
CLEAR.
YOU WANT MORE OF SCHUMER AND
PELOSI?
THEN GO, AHEAD, VOTE FOR THE
POPULOUS FRAUDS